it is a long four years since Andy
Serkis children saw their father now he
could be home within days I got a phone
call from the Foreign Office saying that
under gacho is going to be pardoned by
the government and then I thought 1:00
p.m. she called me and said it's not
official and it's been confirmed until
he's sitting in this room do you think
you'll really believe no no I don't
think so I mean I'll definitely be
tracking the flight yeah so that's how
ya know Andy was born in Ethiopia where
he became an outspoken critic of the
government was this he moved to London
and was granted British citizenship but
in 2014 was kidnapped at an airport in
Yemen and take him back to Ethiopia
where he was put on death row what will
you do with him I think the first thing
I do is I just tackle him in the hope
enough but I think I'll just play games
with him catch up and tell him
everything that he's with the families
campaign for his freedom has been
relentless and on a visit to Ethiopia
last year the Foreign Secretary Boris
Johnson said he'd raised the case with
the country's leadership but Yemi
believes it is the arrival of a new
prime minister there which has finally
triggered the pardon I think if he OPI
had made a decision that they needed to
do in the interest of I think they said
it's expanding of dialogues and and and
making some changes now reunion is
within touching distance but only after
a long ordeal that are the Britain's
light NASA needs a Gary Ratcliffe
imprisoned in Iran are still going
through this families message is to
never give up hope
Olivia Kinsley's Sky News